on 8 news now time to treat yourself
ladies on this international women's day
rocky thea showing us the local shop
that makes prioritizing self-care
sweet and easy hey rocky
so we took a bubble bath earlier as you
know celebrating international women's
day we all deserve
a bubble bath a sweet one at that don't
eat the cake though it's it's not cake
it's soap
all right so now my the advice that i
received here is when you take a shower
you have to scrub right absolutely that
is the key to a to an effective shower
apparently
you know after actually you know washing
yourself so let's talk about the um
mineral sea salt bath bar here that you
can enjoy you come in and you do a
custom
bath salt so how does it work so step by
step
it's a custom build you can add all of
your salts and then from here the next
step that we're going to do is we're
going to add our fragrance
it's going to be the honey honey oat
fragrance
i'm going to throw some in there do the
rest of it in there
and it smells so good you guys as soon
as you walk in it's just it just hits
you
and then go ahead and give it a little
bit of a shake okay perfect
it's like a little martini this is so
fun and obviously diy
we love that because we can come here
and get things pre-made and made for us
but
you can also get all these ingredients
at home and do it yourself
all right okay there we go once we're
done shaking we're going to add a few
more ingredients
okay i see honey i got some honey in the
scrub so
honey is going to soften and smooth the
skin we're going to throw a scoop of
that in there
and then from there we're going to add
some coconut milk
and what does that do that's a unique
product to put in a bath coconut
is very good for irritated skin
it's going to help out with the
irritated skin and then also remove some
dead skin cells
oh and that's good especially nowadays
since most of us are at home
you only have you have to remove the
dead skin okay
for that smooth skin perfect beautiful
oh my gosh
then we're finished and then you just
pour it in the bottle and and people can
come down and buy these pre-made right
absolutely that is delicious
perfect and after you do a scrub i
learned also
that the key is moisturizing of course
moisturizing have the answer
for us as well yes so we have cream one
um it's really unique it actually comes
in two sizes here
so we've got our large and our small i'm
gonna try it and then
here you go so what makes this so
special so
not just like a body butter it's
actually whipped up a lot lighter and
smoother
super bothering this is amazing oh my
gosh i can just imagine this all over
this is self-care utopia
okay sweet bubble fast infections you
guys i'm having so much fun and happy
international women's day
ladies and men too get into it take care
of ourselves
you deserve it i'll send it back to you